bienvenue dans votre nouvelle émission à
free connecte chaque semaine elle nous
évoquerons les problématiques du
continent avec des invités et nous irons
sur place avec des reportages nous
sommes avec akon ou bucco économiste
commissaire togolais à l'uemoa
l'institution monétaire ouest africaine
auteur de l ouvrage du franc cfa à
l'écho demain la souveraineté monétaire
avec un point d'interrogation aux
éditions de l'aube et la fondation jean
jaurès
bonjour à vous qu a connus au boucau et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour cette première émission bonjour
alors évidemment on va parler avec vous
bien sûr de cette fameuse souveraineté
monétaire auquel aspirent les pays
africains est ce que la réforme du franc
cfa va permettre de couper ce cordon
ombilical avec la france puisque le
français fall down monnet ouest
africaine est arrimée à l'euro et que la
future monnaie destiné à la remplacer
tarde à venir dernier calendrier proposé
par la cedeao et bien lancement à
l'horizon 2027 mais avec le début de la
crise sanitaire et bien c'est un
processus qui a pris du retard il doit
reprendre normalement en 2022 alors
justement cette réforme du franc cfa ne
semble pas faire l'unanimité sur le
continent manque de clarté de volonté
politique méfiance des populations eh
bien nous sommes allés prendre le pouls
au sénégal reportage à dakar signé lee
la fin à mosou
le franc cfa est la cible de nombreuses
critiques imprimés en france est accusée
d'être une monnaie néocolonial il
devrait être remplacé par l'écho mais de
cette nouvelle monnaie dont dépendront
des lyon d'africains il subsiste encore
beaucoup de questions peu de réponses et
surtout une grande défiance dans les
rues dakaroise où nous sommes rendus à
locaux qui va raviver sa salle à
connaissent comme le cfa tant que ça
vient pas de chez nous donc c'est pas de
chez nous qu'on a une bonne banque
centrale de nous mêmes tout cela n'est
que de la monnaie importés l'afrique
doit s'unir pour créer sa propre monnaie
indépendant on ne peut pas se développer
tant que la france vous dis que nous
devons faire il ne faut pas accepter
dans la france vient l'eau ou bien même
les autres pays nous impose
qui ne nous arrange pas et la confusion
est d'autant plus présente que
l'appellation échos recouvre en réalité
deux visions de conception de projets
radicalement opposées d'un côté le
projet d'une union monétaire dont rêvent
les 15 pays de la cedeao la communauté
économique des pays d'afrique de l'ouest
et de l'autre la réforme du franc cfa
porté par emmanuel macron et son
homologue ivoirien alassane ouattara une
monnaie également baptisé eco et qui
s'en posent aux huit pays de l'uemoa
l'union économique et monétaire ouest
africaine le projet de monnaie commune
annoncé par les chefs d'état de la
cedeao en juin 2019 nécessite des
changements conséquents selon
l'économiste demba moussa dembélé
l'écho signifie la disparition de toutes
les monnaies en cours au niveau national
comme le nerf au nigeria où le sidi
aughana et bien sûr le cfa dans l'est du
pays qu'ils utilisent sa déco ça vous
dit disparition de francs cfa la
deuxième chose c'est que les coûts ne va
pas avoir de taux de change fixes par
rapport à l'eau et il y aura une banque
centrale qui va avoir la mainmise sur
la définition de politiques monétaires
dans la cedeao
un projet de monnaie à l'opposé de celui
défendu par le tandem macron ouattara
quand la cdo appelé cette décision en
juin 2019 alassane ouattara dix jours
après est allé à paris et il a essayé de
rassurer emmanuel macron et les milieux
français qui ont leurs intérêts en
afrique mais la vive réaction de
l'opinion africaine et si tu du nigeria
et des autres pays est la pandémie bien
sûr tout cela a empêché
l'aboutissement du projet franco
ivoirien de nombreux militants africains
estiment que les cours proposés par
emmanuel macron et alassane ouattara
n'est rien d'autre qu'une opération de
communication
l'écho c'est de la cosmétique l'écho
c'est de prendre tout juste une voiture
néocolonial c'est de prendre la voiture
mais au colonial de changer la
carrosserie mais de laisser tel quel le
moteur dont l'objectif est d'être au
service de l'impérialisme je ne parle
bien entendu pas de l'éco cedeao je
parle de neko emmanuel macron et
ouattara voilà c'est de cet écolabel on
se parle qui a été à l'origine des
premières décisions
c'est le gouvernement français qui a
pris une décision qui année à
l'assemblée nationale française
soumettre un projet le sénat français
s'est réunie jusqu'à présent avez vous
entendu un seul gouvernement africains
plancher sur ça en attendant le nigeria
et le ghana elle les deux plus grandes
économies de la région ont été très
clair il n'envisage vont pas une monnaie
unique tant que les pays qui utilisent
le franc cfa n'auront pas couper le
cordon ombilical avec la france si cette
monnaie commune parvenait à voir le jour
la cedeao pourrait devenir la dix
huitième puissance économique du monde
devant la turquie la suisse et l'arabie
saoudite
alors qu'a connu beaucoup vous l'avez
entendu beaucoup doutent que le
lancement de cette nouvelle monnaie et
co constitue une rupture avec les ex
pays colonisateurs la france dites nous
pourquoi les pays africains de la zone
euro doivent se libérer du franc cfa
oui tout d'abord je voudrais dire qui
aura qu'une monnaie échos si ce sera
l'écho de l'ensemble de la cedeao donc
déco à 15 et à ça c'est quelque chose
qui me paraît fondamental ensuite il
faut insister sur le fait que nous
sommes dans un processus
les pays de la zone franc vont aller
progressivement vers l'éco de la cedeao
les pays de la z mao donc la seconde
zone monétaire ouest africaine également
donc le nigeria le ghana la gambie le
sierra leone le liberia la guinée
conakry vont également progressivement
aller vers cette monnaie échos de la
cedeao est bien évidemment de facto il y
aura la rupture du cordon ombilical avec
la france parce que il est hors de
question que la france
garantissent une monnaie cedeao à 15 ça
ça n'aurait vraiment aucun sens or
justement le remplacement du franc cfa
par l'écho on l'a entendu a été annoncée
par les présidents ivoiriens et français
alassane ouattara et emmanuel macron
c'était le 21 décembre 2019 on sait ce
qui va changer et finalement c'est le
nom de la monnaie francs cfa qui va
disparaître terminé aussi le dépôt des
réserves de change en france et plus de
représentant français au sein des
institutions de gouvernance financière
africaine il ya quand même des flous
concernant la parité aussi la garantie
de la france notamment pour la zone
uemoa de huit pays alors finalement
c'est quoi une vraie ou une fausse
réforme oui il ya deux choses qui sont
importantes mais sans thil est la
première chose c est l annonce de d en
2019 par les présidents français
ivoiriens que j'ai salué parce que de
facto on reconnaissait qu'il y avait un
problème avec le cfa donc on sortait le
débat sur le cfa de l'informel ensuite
il ya une seconde chose c'est une
confusion les du fait qu'on a voulu
donner au successeur du franc cfa
échos alors que l'écho répondait un
autre agenda qu'un agenda de la cedeao
depuis 1983 ce qui fait que on se
retrouve avec deux dispositifs qui n'ont
rien à voir l'un avec l'autre mais qui
donne l'impression d'être la même chose
et donc nous notre rôle en tant
qu'économiste c'est d'aider à clarifier
les choses et pour moi les choses sont
très simples les chefs d'état de la
cedeao ont dit deux choses on veut une
monnaie échos flexible et un régime de
ciblage de l'inflation
à l'heure actuelle le cfa et un taux de
change fixe avec l'euro et avec un taux
d'inflation une cible d'inflation de 2 %
ça veut dire que on voit bien ce qui
doit bouger ce n'est pas ce qui était
décidé à 15 qui va bouger mais c'est ce
qui existe aujourd'hui pour les huit
états de l'ue et moi qui devra bouger
pour s'adapter à la monnaie à 15
depuis 2010 neuf en tout cas on va de
report en report pour le lancement de
l'écho la faute dit on à la crise
sanitaire est ce que c'est réellement la
réalité est par ailleurs 2027 est ce que
c'est une date crédible pour le
lancement de la future monnaie
oui il ya deux choses qui me paraissait
intéressante c'est que d'une part on a
mis en place des critères de convergence
qui peuvent donner l'impression d'une
automaticité dans le processus de
création d'une monnaie à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de la cedeao et la seconde
chose c'est que de facto en mines m le
volet politique la dimension politique
est ce que nous disons dans cet ouvrage
ne tienne ouvrage collectif c'est que
c'est la politique qui va être au coeur
du processus de création monétaire parce
que la monnaie est un fait social total
ce n'est pas qu'on fait économique c'est
un fait sociologique un fait historique
quelquefois même un féru dieu est un
fait éminemment politique et donc cette
monnaie cedeao ne pourrait être un
succès que si un véritable engagement
des états en termes de solidarité
solidarité à deux niveaux au niveau de
la mutualisation des réserves de chance
et puis au niveau de ce qu'on appelle un
embryon de fédéralisme budgétaire il
faudrait qu'il y ait de la solidarité
budgétaire c'est à ces deux conditions
mais sans thil qu'on peut avoir une
monnaie échos qui soit au service du
développement des populations alors
justement dans votre ouvrage du franc
cfa à l'éco demain la souveraineté
monétaire je précise avec un point
d'interrogation aux éditions de l'aube
et la fondation jean jaurès vous
énumérez finalement les quatre options
envisagées pour l'éco un faire de l'éco
un simple avatar du franc cfa avec un
élargissement progressif des pays de
l'uemoa la zone cedeao 2-1 et co fondé
sur le ratio pib par tête 3-1 et koné
rare la monnaie nigériane mais vous
l'expliqué aussi la réforme
franco-ivoirienne franco africaines ont
été refroidis abuja qui se montrent
méfiants désormais face à une réforme du
franc cfa et puis quatrième option
l'écho une monnaie commune et non unique
et c'est cette quatrième option que vous
défendez pourquoi cette quatrième option
est la bonne
oui cette quatrième option est la bonne
pour pour une raison simple c'est que
elle n'empêche pas à terme la mise en
place d'une monnaie unique
mais elle montre quelque part
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier de deux
chemins de solidarité minimale de quoi
s'agit-il et nous avons énuméré quatre
points le premier point c'est qu'elle
est notre objectif la transformation
structurelle des économies ouest
africaine parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
va créer les emplois et de l'activité
notamment pour nos jeunes le principe je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure c'est le
principe de solidarité
avec mutualisation des réserves de
change et coopération budgétaire le
troisième élément c'est un écho monnaie
commune qui va être défini à partir d'un
panier de devises nous en avons
identifié quatre l'euro le dollar le yen
et la livre sterling et le chemin c'est
que les monnaies nationales plus le cfa
à l'heure actuelle vont être un taux de
change fixes mais ajustables avec cette
monnaie pivot qui se rallient qu étant
va créer en plus un tunnel dans lequel
vont fluctuer tout sermonnait autour de
l'éco donc vous voyez c'est un chemin de
convergence progressive qui devrait à
terme nous permettent d'obtenir la
monnaie unique et donc le principe
philosophique c'est qui peut le plus
peut le moins et donc nous pensons que
la proche gradualiste est la meilleure
et c'est pour ça que la déclaration de
lomé va dans ce sens qu'a connu boucau
nous allons marquer à une courte pause
et se retrouver pour poursuivre à
évoquer donc cette souveraineté
monétaire on se retrouve dans un instant
dans l'âtre icône est resté avec nous
sur rt france
retour dans la fri connect nous sommes
avec qu'a connu bucco économiste et nous
évoquons avec lui la souveraineté
monétaire des pays africains justement
là la grande question c'est l'objet
d'ailleurs de votre ouvrage 1 du franc
cfa l'écho demain la souveraineté
monétaire pour l'interrogation comment
ces pays africains peuvent atteindre
cette souveraineté monétaire parce que
ce n'est pas seulement la réforme du
franc cfa qui est en jeu
oui vous savez le astier passionnant
avec la question monétaire c'est que
c'est une question sociétale et donc
nous on pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient de
la pédagogie il faut que les dirigeants
que les députés que les chercheurs que
les universitaires puissent multiplier
les prises de parole les lieux de débat
la pédagogie afin que les populations se
sentent concernés par ce qui se passe il
n'y a rien de pire que d'avoir
l'impression d'avoir un débat hors sol
alors que ce qui compte c'est la vie des
400 millions que nous sommes dans la
cedeao et c'est pour ça que moi à titre
personnel je me suis engagé depuis une
vingtaine d'années sur ces questions
monétaires
parce que c'est au coeur
du crédit productif vous savez
l'occident s'est développée
historiquement grâce au crédit productif
et donc la monnaie pour nous ce n'est
pas une simple question identitaire
c'est le canal par lequel ou en tout cas
un des canaux par lesquels nous pouvons
réussir à lutter contre le chômage et
partant les les tentatives d'émigration
massive de nos jeunes on ne peut pas
accepter qu'un continent aussi dynamique
que l'afrique ne puisse pas être
financés du point de vue des activités
génératrices de revenus
s'agissant justement du système actuel
du franc cfa vous savez que les cris de
l'une des principales critiques a été
réduite en miettes un peu par un rapport
du sénat française il ya un an c'était
sur le bilan de la zone franc dans ce
rapport ce qui se dit c'est que
l'obligation de détenir une partie des
réserves sur un compte d'opérations
auprès du trésor ne constitue pas en
réalité une taxe pour les paysans
africains et ce n'est pas aussi un moyen
de financer la dette française et cela
au détriment des économies locales que
pensez vous de ce bilan établi par des
sénateurs français
oui moi je pense vraiment que le le
débat n'est plus à ce niveau
il y a des gens qui sont dans la défense
d'un système qui a vécu c'est le système
de la françafrique avec le franc cfa qui
me semble être le dernier avatar de la
colonisation française en afrique donc
il faut arrêter d'essayer de défendre
coûte que coûte ce système l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment financer les
économies réelles ouest africaine et
pour ça nous devons tous se retrousser
nos manches et et voir comment nous
devrions procéder
avec la réforme actuelle les ressources
ont été rétrocédés à la banque centrale
des états de l'afrique de l'ouest nous
espérons qu'elle saura bien placé cet
argent de sorte que sa trésorerie ne
puisse pas trop en souffrir mais surtout
qu'elles puissent comprendre qu' à
l'aggiornamento
hop l'international sur le plan
monétaire c'est que toutes les banques
centrales du monde aujourd'hui financent
l'économie parce que c'est la seule
façon d'échapper à la crise liée
notamment à la pandémie de co vite alors
il ya des défenseurs quand même du franc
cfa d'ailleurs parmi eux vous comptez un
ami etienne geros qui est président
délégué du cian le conseil français des
investisseurs en afrique et on précise
il n'est pas contre les colas future
monnaie ouest africaine on l'écoutait
kacou est un ami que je connais bien on
débat très très souvent ensemble et il
sait très bien qu'on n'est pas d'accord
sur tout parce que je pense que il faut
sortir d'une vision historique
et un petit peu sentimentale de cette
question monétaire il faut regarder
simplement ce qui permet à l'économie se
développer aux investisseurs de venir et
au pouvoir d'achat de tenir à peu près
car vous savez aussi que si on opère par
exemple de l'évaluation forte ça
favorise effectivement les exportations
et donc peut-être une industrie régions
du pays mais ça appauvrit aussi la
population puisque en afrique une des
caractéristiques c'est beaucoup de biens
consommés sont importés donc si vous
d'évaluer ça augmente quand le franc cfa
a dévalué de 50% en 1994 ça voulait dire
que tout ce qui est importé sert
quasiment tous les biens consommés par
la population ont en gros en cfa tous
les prix le lendemain matin ça coûte
elle double les livres scolaires une
partie des aliments à porter les
équipements etc etc l'avantagé d'une
monnaie tels que francs cfa il est assez
connu d'abord c'est effectivement une
monnaie qui a empêché en gros
l'inflation
alors qu'à que nous beaucoup premier
point évoqué par votre ami etienne giro
c'est vrai est-ce que la dévaluation n'a
pas que finalement des bons côtés votre
avis là-dessus
oui ce que je voudrais dire à mon ami
etienne 0 1 et je le lui dis souvent
c'est que il ne faut pas qu'il oublie
que le franc cfa c'est le véhicule par
excellence de l'accumulation de
richesses hors d'afrique c'est à dire
qu'il ya trois caractéristiques du cfa
qui est qui qui qui sont importantes le
taux de change fixe avec l'heureux vous
l'avez rappelé mais aussi la totale
garantie de convertibilité
quand vous avez dû scier faire vous avez
de l'euro et enfin la totale liberté de
circulation des capitaux dont vous
pouvez placer librement vos ressources
cfa dans la zone euro et donc quand vous
avez ces trois caractéristiques le franc
cfa de viesly très bonne monnaie pour ce
que moi j'appelle l'économie dans pire
les grands groupes qui font des affaires
en afrique et qui placent leurs
bénéfices dans la zone euro et donc nous
en afrique on est obligé de reprendre
chaque année le cycle d'accumulation
primitive du capital et donc je
comprends etienne durot ce qui est un
nombre des grands groupes français le
font ses phalanges mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les millions de
petits producteurs africains qui ont
besoin d'être financé la zone cfa venait
pas de taux d'intérêt inférieur à deux
chiffres alors que nous sommes en taux
de change fixe avec l'euro et dans la
zone euro les taux d'intérêt sont
proches de zéro alors expliquez-moi ce
qui peut caractériser une telle
différence n'ont qu'un point deuxième
point est troisième point évoqué aussi
par étienne géraud d'abord la parité
fixe avec dick c'est un booster
d'investissement sur le long terme et
puis stabilité des prix - d'inflation
cela permet d'avoir finalement une
croissance aussi moins volatile
non c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est un système qui alimente
l'extraversion des économies vous voyez
le franc cfa est
extraversion économique ces deux faces
d'une même médaille est à dire on est on
ne transforme pas les produits sur place
on exporte les matières premières et
avec les recettes d'exportation les deux
vis en garantit la parité fixe entre le
cfa et l'euro mais tout ça ne fait pas
une économie qui se développe et
lorsqu'on me parle d'inflation jeudi le
malade meurt guéri je préfère une
économie qui crée des emplois et qui
supporte un peu d'inflation à une
économie qui ne crée aucun emploi mais
avec l'inflation nulle puisque justement
un taux d'inflation nulle ça veut dire
que vous ne faites rien et donc je suis
surpris de cet argument d'un cfa qui
garantirait une inflation faible c'est
simplement une façon de dire que c'est
la monnaie des élites et je ne peux pas
avec une population qui double tous les
25 ans avec un âge médian de 19 ans
m'empêcher de réfléchir à un instrument
monétaire qui soit au service au
bénéfice de la croissance intérieure et
du marché intérieur west afric alors
quelques nous beaucoup nous avons
également recueilli quelques questions
au sénégal on va écouter la première
question si j'avais une économiste
devant moi
j'allais lui poser la question
quels sont les intérêts du nouveau
monnaie ego vis-à-vis des africains plus
précisément des africains de l'ouest
quelques nouveaux co
oui le premier intérêt c'est que l'écho
à 15 l'écho de la cedeao sera notre
monnaie
sait on peut mal la gérer on peut bien
la gérer mais c'est notre monnaie le
franc cfa c'est le monde c'est la
monnaie du colonisateur elle est née le
26 décembre 1945 et ce n'est pas notre
monnaie on aurait de changer cette
monnaie au moment des indépendances
je ne sais pas pourquoi on l'a fait mais
pourquoi on ne l'a pas fait mais
aujourd'hui il est temps de procéder à
cela donc la question de la souveraineté
me semble d'abord déterminante après on
peut discuter de la question économique
dont j'ai suffisamment dit qu'elle va
nous permettre justement de financer les
économies réelles ouest africaine et
régler la question du chômage au moins
en partie alors deuxième question à
quelques nouveaux coups on écoute tout
de suite quelles sont les garanties pour
que cette monnaie tissu l'écho d'une
monnaie forte de puissantes et qui
permettra même aux africains avec cette
monnaie de pouvoir être compétitifs que
nous beaucoup c'est une question à
laquelle vous répondez dans votre
ouvrage d'ailleurs oui tout à fait c'est
à dire que l'objectif pour moi ce n'est
pas que l'écho soit une monnaie forte
c'est que l'écho permettent de créer de
l'activité et des emplois
après si notre économie devient forte de
facto la monnaie sera considérée comme
forte au sens de désirable par les
agents économiques extérieures le yuan
chinois on ne peut pas considérer que ce
soit une monnaie forte mais tout le
monde sait que la puissance de
l'économie réelle chinoise donne une
crédibilité au noir chinois
alors outre la souveraineté monétaire
vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué tout à
l'heure il ya un enjeu important un
catalyseur même il s'agit de
l'intégration monétaire il ya des
instruments des outils pour cela dans
votre ouvrage vous analysez d'ailleurs
la structure de la bceao la banque
centrale des états d'afrique de l'ouest
de l'uemoa sur le modèle vous dit
finalement de la banque centrale
européenne est-ce qu'il faut revoir tous
ces modèles d'institutions financières y
compris la cedeao qui est d'ailleurs
même critiqué pour son action ou
inaction politique oui tout à fait c'est
à dire qu'il faut mettre ce que moi
j'appelle le contrôle citoyen de
l'action publique et donc le contrôle
citoyen de nos institutions nous avons
hérité beaucoup d'institutions
par mimétisme
nous avons peur de les modifier il est
clair que dans la construction monétaire
que nous sommes en train d'effectuer il
faudra voir la structure idoine de la
banque centrale est-ce qu'elle va être
fédéral est ce que elle va être plutôt
comme la bcéao actuellement c'est à dire
une seule banque centrale avec des
succursales dans chaque état il faut
qu'on étudie la question de l'union
bancaire est ce que la commission
bancaire de l'uemoa telle qu'on la
connaît a vocation à devenir la
commission bancaire des 15 sachant qu'on
n'a pas les mêmes traditions juridiques
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du marché financier
aujourd'hui on a la bourse régionale des
valeurs mobilières d'abidjan
mais il y à la bourse du nigeria la
bourse du ghana comment coordonne tout
ça donc je comprends que l'horizon de
mise en place de cette monnaie puisse
être peu long actuellement parle de 2027
mais la pire des choses serait de
croiser les bras et d'attentes 2020 7
pour dire on va faire une monnaie il
faut dès maintenant travail sur tous les
ressorts notamment institutionnels de la
mise en place d'une monnaie idoine merci
beaucoup à vous qu a connu beaucoup je
le rappelle vous êtes économiste
commissaire togolais à l'uemoa auteurs
de cet ouvrage facile à lire finalement
sous forme de question du franc cfa à
l'éco demain la souveraineté monétaire
aux éditions de l'aube et la fondation
jean jaurès
merci et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis merci également à nadia florian
léa aux équipes techniques pour la
préparation de cette émission afrique
connect c'est sur vos réseaux sociaux et
en replay sur notre site arte france
point tv à très bientôt dans un free
connecte sur rt france